[Music]
Steve haze them a foundation professor
of psychology at the University of
Nevada
well I'm in psychology probably a lot of
people get into psychology you're
interested in why there's so much pain
and suffering around you I certainly saw
that at home just growing up and decided
early on that it was a place to put my
science interests and also this my
humanitarian interests and you could put
those two together in one field after I
was a psychologist I developed a panic
disorder and that changed a lot of what
kind of work I'd I do because I was
trained as a paper therapist and as a
cognitive behavior therapist and when I
applied the methods that I would apply
with others when they had panic disorder
it didn't really fully hit what I
thought what was needed for me and I
turned back towards things several
things that were sort of in my
experience from more Eastern traditions
human potential traditions and then
tried to marry that up I'm a child of
the 60s and grew up in California so was
exposed to the kind of garden-variety
eastern thinking that most folks in my
generation were exposed to and I
actually found more in mindfulness and
acceptance kind of methods that were
directly benefit to me then in the
traditions I was nominally part of so
that really changed my thinking and that
caused me to set out on about a 30-year
journey as to how to dig down to the
essence of what's inside some of our
deepest clinical traditions but also our
spiritual and religious traditions
particularly these Eastern traditions
but not just that all of the mystical
wings of the major spiritual religious
traditions have methods that are
designed to change how you interact with
your logical analytical linear thinking
and I didn't want to leave that just
intact I didn't want to simply be a
meditation teacher or something I wanted
to understand it and we spent a lot of
time kind of pulling it as a joint and
trying to understand
why these things might be helpful to
people I think particularly helpful to
people in the modern world who are
exposed through the media and the kind
of chattering world that we've created
to a lot of horror a lot of pain a lot
of judgment a lot of words and need to
find a place to to go that is more
peaceful and more empowering being able
to live their lives an intimate
committed effective way so it's kind of
how I came there where I ended up where
I ended up
well the empirical clinical traditions
especially in the cognitive behavioral
tradition early on they're trying to
apply behavioral principles mostly
developed with animal models directly to
people and there's a lot of benefit that
happened there it's still relevant today
you can do a lot of good things for
people who suffer with anxiety
depression and so on using those methods
I'm old enough to have seen all three of
these steps and somewhere in the late
70s and mid 80s people realized that you
had to have a better way of dealing with
cognition and they couldn't find it in
the animal models so they went to more
common-sense clinical models where they
would sort of divide thinking styles up
into rational and irrational processes
making cognitive errors and so forth and
they thought if you get just just get
people to think more rationally and
focus on the evidence and take some of
those over expansive thoughts that are
creating difficulty for them and change
them then they do better and someone was
in the techniques were helpful but the
theory didn't work very well
increasingly over time we learned that
the components they tell you to put that
theory tells you to put in and the
processes that should change didn't
really explain the outcomes and add to
the outcomes and it had this potential
for downside people can get even more
self focused even more caught up and you
know their own thinking and we're part
of a newer so the third generation of
that tradition that is using acceptance
and mindfulness practices and values
commitment behavior change practices and
marrying them up so the difference
between traditional CBT and the
acceptance and commitment therapy or act
but not just act also mindfulness based
cognitive therapy dialectical behavior
therapy a number of the other more kind
of modern acceptance and mindfulness
approaches and says instead of teaching
people to detect it to challenge the
dispute and change their thinking we
teach people to notice what they're
thinking and to notice what they're
feeling what their body
doing learn from it but then focus also
on their values and getting their feet
moving towards the kinds of lives that
they want to produce to have a life
worth living and turns out that that's
we think a quicker and more direct way a
more certain way to moving ahead in your
life than first trying to get the
cognitive ecology inside this skull of
ours all lined up with an ability to
detect our logical errors and correct
them and so forth meanwhile the clock is
ticking
there's relationships to have children
to be raised work to be done
contributions to be made and you're
waiting to get the world within all
lined up we think it's more effective to
find a way to back up from that a little
bit notice that see what's there learn
from it and move ahead directly towards
the kind of lives that you want to
produce and it turns out those processes
are not just in therapy but in this
office in your home in the schools and
organizations and so the act work has
very quickly expanded out from
psychotherapy into behavioral medicine
and from that even into organizational
work and now into prevention work and
the communities in schools so it's kind
of exciting to see psychology touching
people where they are so in the streets
in a way that is empowering and sort of
simplifies what it is that people need
to learn to be more effective and a
happy successful vital in their lives
full of things if someone watching this
were to focus on what pains them the
most and then it would take the time to
look inside what do I care about such
that that's particularly painful they're
probably going to find a significant
area that they value a given example
most people are hurt deeply by betrayals
and relationships and what your mind
tells you to do is you know don't be so
vulnerable don't be so silly don't open
yourself up don't be so trusting you can
be betrayed in fact the reason why it's
you hurt so much is that you want
relationships that are loving committed
intimate you want trust and what your
mind's telling you to do in a way is
don't care about that so much so that
you won't be hurt so much it might be
better to really get up against and sort
of contact that caring and maybe take a
more loving stance even with your own
pain and keep your feet moving towards
what you really want because the cost in
terms of intimacy and connection and
caring that comes when you try not to be
vulnerable when you're constantly
looking out for betrayals of trust is
too great
and makes it very hard to have
relationships of the kind that you
really want so there there's an example
one look where the pain is flip it over
you'll find that's where the values are
another one is just to think of the
times that you felt most with yourself
most connected most vital most energized
most flowing natural and if you take
some of these specific memories and you
walk inside them you're gonna find that
there's things in there that you care
about there's things in there that when
it's really working well that it are
kind of a lighthouse like a beacon in
the distance that you can move towards
you never fully reach these things I
mean give you an example there are times
when you felt especially important to
another person or
cared about or loved or accepted well
loving relationships aren't something
you can have like a you know oppress
this little jewel you put in a box and
then put on your shelf it's something
you walk towards and there's always
difficulties there's always pain and
relationships but you can keep walking
towards that beacon in the distance that
process that journey is called life and
if you're moving towards the things that
you value life is more vital flowing
that it's more empowering and so that's
another way go inside the sweetness of
life catch the places where you
genuinely removed by are connected with
life and you'll find in there a kind of
a light that can direct you and it gets
them in the cacophony gets very noisy
and you get confused and lost that can
direct you towards what you care about
a little bit because this psychology is
a psychology of the normal a lot of the
psychologists that are out there are
built on the psychology psychology they
have normal we have all these syndra
mailboxes that we can put people in and
so forth the actual evidence on
syndromes is not very good I mean
there's no specific biological marker
for example for any of the things that
you see talking about in the media even
things like schizophrenia there's no
specific and sensitive biological
markers for these things so yeah there
may be some abnormal processes involved
in some of them but vastly more of human
suffering comes from normal processes
that are run away from us like normal
processes of problem-solving work great
on the world without when it's applied
within you to easily get into a mode of
mind where you can start living when the
problem of your history is solved but
your history is not going to go away it
isn't the same thing as dirt on the
floor or paint peeling off the walls
it's not going to be solved in that way
it's more like learning how to carry at
the contact it to see it because it's
based on the psychology of the normal
with a therapist as part of that too and
so when the purpose gets in there and is
working on acceptance and mindfulness
and values they too are working with
those very same processes and so it
requires a therapist not to be a master
at it you don't even have to be good at
it but just to see the value of it and
to be willing to to look at their own
difficult emotions and thoughts and find
a way to carry them gently in the
service of the clients that they're
serving so for example if a therapist is
feeling insecure in therapy a lot of
therapists will try to sort of push that
too aside to try to do the therapy
instead we would ask people to get with
that feeling of insecurity because after
all the client is being asked to do the
same thing so it tends to be relatively
intense interactive horizontal it's not
one up the therapist is in the same soup
and
it has a kind of equality of two human
beings in the same situation really
working through these psychological
processes and yeah I'm working for you
you hired me I'm working for you as a
therapist but I'm not up here and you're
down there and what you're struggling
with you know at other times and with
other areas I'm struggling with
well and even more than that I mean that
I've mentioned even in this office you
know the same processes are there we've
done research showing that act and the
processes that underlie it can help
things like and secretaries learn new
software can therapists learn new
methods what about stigma and Prejudice
between people so it isn't just in the
psychotherapy areas and why that would
be as an empirical fact there's a pretty
enormous breadth to these methods and
the why that would be because everywhere
that a human mind goes these processes
of avoiding the world within in order to
try to regulate your behavior or
becoming entangled in your thoughts
interfering with your ability to take
advantage of of what's around you or
losing contact with your values for fear
that you'll know more about the places
where you hurt those kinds of processes
are just normal psychological processes
that are built-in to language and
cognition itself they're built into
problem-solving and so if you take the
mode of mind that works great in 95
percent of your life and apply it within
it then implodes it it starts creating
barriers and that's true at work it's
true in our organizations that's true in
our culture during our politics and yeah
it's true in our consulting rooms so
we're going the reason why it spreads
out we have pretty good evidence for
this I know it sounds a little grandiose
but the mental cognitive processes that
we're targeting are ones that narrow
human beings repertoire and make it
harder for them to learn to be more
flexible to take advantage of the
opportunities in front of them and we
think that's something we can have
something to say about some of the help
within all of these different areas
maybe even in areas like child
development or organizations and schools
or maybe even things like prevention or
how people's interact with each other
one day
so we've taken the work for example into
things like prejudice and stigma because
in the modern world if we can't solve
that we have planes flying into
buildings and then we have planes flying
over countries you know the amount of
hate and objectification and
dehumanization that's on the planet
isn't something we can tolerate anymore
in a world and that's coming of suitcase
bombs and the ability to amplify that
hate out into harm towards each other so
it applies broadly because anywhere that
a human mind goes these processes go
there's many different definitions of it
well I think one dangerous definition of
it is to think of happiness as kind of a
warm joyful mostly feeling in your heart
that you have to pursue and grab and
hold on to for a fear that it'll go away
and it's fun when you have those
feelings but we know when the evidence
shows the more intent you are of having
those feelings and chasing those
feelings that's a butterfly that flies
away the more you chase it a better way
to think about happiness that actually
is something that I think you can reach
tour is its living in accord with your
values and in a way that is more open
and accepting of your history as it
echoes into the present that's more self
affirming self validating and
values-based the Greeks had a word for
it they called it eudaimonia and it's
not a bad definition and I think that
definition of happiness is something
that will empower human lives the
definition that we have that gets very
hedonistic and emotion oriented the
problem is there's too many quick and
dirty ways to chase that in ways that
end up being unhelpful to people if you
avoid the feelings of betrayal in a
sense of insecurity that comes in
relationships that aren't working by
running into you know detuned
relationships by sexuality that isn't
connected to intimacy etc yeah you might
feel good but it doesn't live well if
you you know just have another martini
or even more severe forms of substance
use yeah it might feel good but it
doesn't live well and if you escape into
you know kind of a materialism and the
right car the right woman the right
house the right trip the right place the
right job the right you know praise the
you know these things all of the folks
who are wiser in our culture over the
history of our culture have written
about the dangers of trying to define
a meaningful life that way but
commercial culture in our media is
constantly encouraging us to think that
if we feel good we live well and then
we'll only to happy thank you very much
to sell you goods and services from the
dancing old voids in the pill you can
take or the trips of the cars or the
clothes or the women that you can get
with whatever that is that will give you
the quick route to that and it's an
empty promise I think I think young
people know it's empty but they're not
quite sure what to do and yeah I I kind
of look at what's on the t-shirts and I
see another solution which also worries
me I see just do it no fear you know
this kind of suppressive response to the
treacle that the culture tries to define
for us as a meaningful life also blows
up on you know fear is not something
that you should put on your shirt how
about I can hold my fear and still
connect with you put that on your shirt
it's okay to be me with all of my
history put that on your shirt so
there's a middle path and I was a guy
who sat under a tree a long time ago who
is important to a pretty big chunk of
the human population who called it the
middle path there is a middle path
between indulgence and suppression but
the culture has overwhelmed that in the
cacophony that has been created in the
modern world and the commercial
encouragement of avoidance and
indulgence on the one hand or
suppression and just do it treating
yourself as an object on the other we've
got to find a way that's more
compassionate softer that allows us to
move forward towards the kind of lives
that we really want to live
I think the commercial culture and also
science and technology after all which
you know gives us greater ease but also
makes it harder for us to sit with the
small amounts of distress that come just
by living itself is probably the
combination of the commercial culture
and the media culture and the science
and technology has probably made it more
difficult in American culture but I
think it's built in the language and
cognition it was only given some
counterweights the major institutions
that are there are our spiritual and
religious traditions which emerged very
early on at the point of which human
language grew and written language you
know created kind of the problem that we
can have now with language kind of
running away from us and those
traditions have weakened - in our
culture and they've changed so we
probably do is that we're chasing
happiness I think we have the wrong
model of happiness I don't
I mean defined as eudaimonia if I
defined as a values based life of
integrity and fidelity to yourself and
what you most deeply want to stand for
that definition of happiness man that's
the kind of life I want to live and I
think that's will support people will
sustain people but this cheap thrill
version this sort of ease definition the
feel-good definition of happiness is is
an empty promise and the culture in the
West I think has done a particularly bad
job of this indulgence in that vision of
what happiness is and encouraging people
to chase it and I think we can see in
the growing amount of problems that we
have in the developed world that it's an
empty promise and I'll give you an
example enough from the US but in
Scandinavia probably the most worker
supportive part of the planet they have
the highest rate of chronic pain and the
greatest rate of worker related
disability so right inside this idea
that any kind of pain and difficulty is
so much unwelcome that if if you
say that you're in pain we're gonna come
in guns a-blazing and even pay you full
salary to quit work because you're
burned out or - you know inside that
what you're gonna create is gigantic
amounts of chronic pain syndrome
Scandinavians spent fifteen percent of
the gross national product on disability
fifty percent of the public health
nurses run disability I mean and that's
where we're headed in the US - because
we unless we get wiser is how to carry
the difficulties of life in a way that's
self compassionate and empowering we can
create this kind of world in which we'd
rather sort of plug into the matrix with
whatever pills or escapists the
tendencies we can think of instead of
walking through a process of living it's
going to include loss it's going to
include limitations on functioning it's
going to include some significant
difficulties we need to learn and teach
our children how to do that and the West
is just doing a terrible job of that
right now
good science and that in big farm is
only too happy to give us bad science
because the way the FDA is set up and
what the requirements are I mean these
are geek topics and the normal person
wouldn't really know how to evaluate it
but you only require a certain number of
randomized trials you don't have to have
the proper control groups you can have
the blind to be penetrated people can
know that they're on the medications
which we know there's a big placebo
effect inside medications so the science
is often inadequate the best science is
out there then I want it then that's
fine
I would let's go there and there's
decent science let's take something like
antidepressant medications there's
decent science saying it has an effect
but it's shockingly small after you
control for penetration of the blind
people knowing that they're getting the
active pills versus sugar pills after
you if you use an active control it's
probably only a few points like in
depression on a 56 point scale the
estimate is it probably accounts for
about two points difference you know but
it's a multi multi-billion dollar
industry and by the way has huge side
effects and some of these medications
forty percent of the people taking them
have significant sexual side effects for
example and that's just one you know the
the level a single antidepressant
medication can be worth a billion
dollars to a company so I want good
science and I want it to be
realistically marketed I wouldn't like I
think all these commercials that we have
or only two countries in the planet that
allow pharmaceutical companies to market
directly to people in New Zealand United
States it's a bad idea in my opinion I
think it ought to be better regulated
and when it's presented to people it
ought to be presented in a way that's
realistic for example often people will
prescribe these medications and will say
you have a brain disease you'll have to
be on these medications permanently it's
because your brain disease
well brain disease there would be a
specific biological marker for the so
called disease there is no biological
marker for the
oppression it's not true that we know
that it's a brain disease is the brain
involved in depression yes the brain is
involved with what you and I are doing
right now neither one of us had a brain
we wouldn't be having a conversation but
that doesn't mean it's a brain disease
and so the prescriber is very often
overstate oversell and the detail people
are only too happy to tell them to do
that this idea that there's something
wrong with your brain and because of
that you're permanently by the way
almost never are these medications
evaluated with what will happen if
you're on them for 3 4 or 5 10 15 years
sometimes some of the side effects that
come up come up
only later and sometimes they're very
severe even a reversible side effects so
I would like it to be more like yes
these medications might be helpful to a
degree but what they do in areas like
depression or antipsychotics is they
give you a little more distance between
the things that cause you to get
entangled with thoughts and feelings and
so they might be of some help now can
open up a little window now can we go in
there and learn some of these methods
directly to do that for example
antidepressant medications you still
have some depressive thoughts
antipsychotic medications you still have
some psychotic symptoms for the vast
majority than people taking them but it
gives them a little separation and it
doesn't controls behavior as much when
you have a sad feeling difficult thought
an odd perceptual experience we can
teach people those exact skills in
therapy and so evidence is pretty good
if you use it as a just a window to get
in there and teach these skills you get
longer-term benefits and without the
side effects so don't be sold just
because a commercial interest wants to
sell you things the government ought to
help out because average citizen can't
go out and be doing we use the
scientific literature and focus on the
processes that have low side effects and
good long-term outcomes right now you're
going to find those in the psychosocial
area and the therapy area and the
empirically supported treatments such as
act or cognitive behave
therapy behavioral therapy and go there
first rather than going to the pill
bottle as if it's going to be the the
end of your journey the sort of its
gonna solve the problem very often it's
only gonna help and even only to a minor
degree and more is going to be needed
well the advice I'd give and if you were
my patient I'd be a little different
because we'd have a little more time but
if I can distill it down to the essence
of what we do in a course of therapy the
person with panic I can say this from
the inside out since you're looking at a
panic disordered person in recovery has
adopted a posture with regard to the
world within in which their own anxiety
is their enemy and they think that if
they can just get the anxiety to go down
go away not occur as much or not occur
with such an intensity or at least not
occur here or there in that situation
that then things would be better in fact
all of that is not the solution to the
problem it is the problem holding
anxiety is your own enemy and that it
has to go down diminish it go away and
not happen here is a kind of self
invalidating interior focused process
that would get you even more entangled
with these processes instead what we're
going to need to learn to do is to allow
your history to bring into the present
thoughts and feelings and memories and
to sort of hold them mindfully and stuff
compassionately and then focus on what
you do and bring them along for that
journey so you know the feelings are
only your history being occasioned by
the present moment if that's your enemy
than your history is your enemy
if sensations are your enemy your body's
your enemy if memory is your enemy you
better have a way of controlling your
mind in such a way that you never
reminded of things that are painful from
the past well there is no such thing
like that that's healthy and most of the
things that people do that are called
psychopathology are the unhealthy things
people do when they try to accomplish
that agenda if you avoided people avoid
having your buttons pushed avoid going
to places that might occasion anxiety if
you're hammering down drugs and alcohol
these are all methods of trying to mount
that unhealthy agenda so I would say
could we instead take this anxiety to be
something that may be of importance may
even be meaningful
and it says something about your history
and could be learned to sort of hold it
in a in a way that's more compassionate
to sort of bring the frightened part of
you close and treat it with some dignity
and keep focused instead on of making
that going go away focused instead on
what kind of life you want to live
connected to what kind of meaning and
purpose that's gonna be a quicker more
self compassion and more certain journey
forward than this kind of out with
things I you know in with the relaxation
you know out with the self-doubt in with
the confidence kind of let's just snap
out of it kind of harsh and and lack of
a non compassionate place that we stand
with ourselves inside things like panic
disorder
it's an argument about theory and
processes but the processes are the ones
we've been talking about inform what we
think of ourselves and what we should
encourage in our children and what we
should try to put into the culture and I
think really we've been through a time
when we thought we could think our way
out of this and kind of think clearly
and that would solve the problem and
detect logical errors and that would
solve the problem we thought of these
suffering as a problem of sort of
dysfunctional cognitions I think we're
coming into a time instead where it has
to do with how you stand in relationship
to your own world within and in
relationship to those around you in the
world without and I believe these are
the things that we need to put into our
schools education indoor psychotherapy
and into our culture more finding a way
to not be so harsh and judgmental
so objectifying and dehumanizing
constantly focused within and trying to
get these difficult thoughts and
feelings to go away or focused without
and objectifying and dehumanizing others
so the core the controversy is is it
more powerful to take an acceptance and
mindfulness based approach compared to a
cognitive and emotional change approach
when we're dealing with these problems I
think the evidence is more in our favor
especially the process evidence and I
think if you look at where the culture
is going there's a reason why Eckhart
Tolle is on Oprah there's a reason why
the you know Purpose Driven Life is a
best-seller quite apart from appealing
to evangelicals and the Christianity
that's in it is also there's a yearning
for meaning for values and for
mindfulness and acceptance because we've
created a modern world where our
children are exposed to 10 20 30 times
the number of words that our
great-grandfather's were exposed to and
we're exposed in a single day or two to
more horror
on our internet web pages then our great
game fathers were exposed to in decades
of living and we have not created modern
minds for that modern world science and
technologies just dumped us in on us and
I think people yearn for it I think you
see it in what's popular you know and
why are people wanting to learn about
meditation and you know why are they
going on mindfulness retreats and why
are they talking about a Purpose Driven
Life that's because they know more needs
more is needed in the modern world and
that's the core of the controversy I
think it's pretty clear and how things
are moving in the purest part of
treatments that we're gonna be speaking
to the culture in a different voice it's
not going to be the loosey-goosey voice
of the 60s but it's going to have some
echoes of some of the deeper clinical
and spiritual and religious traditions
that had wisdom in it if we're not going
to get there through religious means and
things of that kind which greatly is
weakened in the West we're gonna have to
find a way to put it in the culture in a
different way because we need something
right now other than you know yet
another cable shoutcast or yet another
you know Internet web page showing us
this the cellulite on the actress's rear
end I mean the amount of sort of
judgment and harshness that's in our
culture we need a something that's
prophylactic for that and I think that's
what's inside these new methods
right in the positive way is the
possibility that we might contribute to
the development of human culture in a
way that you know years from now people
who will never know our names may be
able to live more empowered lives and
you know if you asked like what is the
name of your great-great
great-grandfather you probably don't
even know if you get three or four
greats out so it's not that we're
immortal we're gonna die very very soon
it's not that what we produce is going
to live on it will not but the changes
that we can make in the culture can be
there for people that we will never meet
it will never know us and that's what
keeps me up at night it's what excites
me about science that we can learn ways
of being with each other and the
behavioral sciences have not been enough
of a part of cultural development the
physical sciences have behavioral
sciences have not and I would like to
see if we can bring some things into
human culture that would human eyes and
soften and empower people what keeps you
up at night in a negative way is if we
don't solve these problems of the human
heart and of the human head of human
psychology
there is no technological solution so
great that it can prevent the world that
is coming in a world of suitcase bombs
or of the ability to pollute the planet
in the way that it cannot recover of
global warming and the rest we've
created through science and technology a
different world that has frightening
sides to it and psychology and
behavioral science has to be part of
this because if you take something like
the so-called war on terrorism but if we
go out another 20 years and it isn't
just planes into buildings but it's a
suitcase bomb in the middle of New York
there's not enough soldiers and there's
not enough bullets to kill enough people
to make us safe I think we're going to
have to find a way to humanize the
culture itself and it isn't just them
it's us when we fly buildings apply
planes over countries dropping
bombs on the evil ones I think we're
doing something very similar to what's
being done when the infidels are getting
there come up and so if planes going to
into buildings so it's it's gotten to
the point where if we are not healthy
psychologically as a human society we
will not have a planet to live on
and that's what keeps me up at night
when I see so little focus on the the
behavioral side of these problems and
the idea that just politics or just
physical science is going to solve this
or just the military it's not true we
have to solve this and we've got to
solve it in our own heads and our own
hearts one at a time and I think
psychotherapy actually tells us a little
bit about what we might need to do to
soften the culture and make it more
possible for us to live together as
human beings on this planet